are we trying to get free curry inside I
got it off in time
wow what a screen sent on Chris Paul on
green leveler and that's a good clean
screen if Paul's rusty mates
responsibility to communicate and let
him know it Iguodala clearly got that
off in time does the coach at the LA
Clippers tighten again switch on these
two ran on top shot clock at seven Jews
we have some three there is a switch on
defense here it's curry it's green the
fit back to James Hart the wall three
and right down the pipe it goes
[Music]
Thompson zigzags into the day and puts
it down with that offhand only 28% Clark
is from three-point territory pipe watch
at Durant stutter step at the drop of
the deuce
13 games in Toronto last year which
waved inside by Golden State they go to
great news a hot fire coming off that
piece line Samantha Texaco
Gordon Bay need rivers to score and play
well which he has so far
[Applause]
EJ Tucker
Tucker is struggling with his shot
clothes III gotta figure it all out
there defending organs if he's going at
one another all my goodness for the
Rockets I mean this is the gifts clay
Thompson a pretty good defender
perimeter defender
[Applause]
Jr's mother
step back
will it between the eyes
[Applause]
seventh rebound curry saves it
I know what the gifts be incredible for
the rocket
[Applause]
got two three you know teams bumps and
occur across the desert opsin frozen
rivers
Austin Rivers a triple two-point rocket
lead makes a move once the ball tries to
get it says sink inside
outside cool
[Applause]
inbound pardon trying to get three down
to three down - Tara - pretty good
James Horton appointed fail incredible
shot have been fouled in the grill of
draymond Green a former Defensive Player
of the Year and he'd been shooting
really well late in the season and 49%
the first round Durant to the basket
warriors must eight on the boards Durant
gets a running start and side
[Applause]
all over the Gordon Gordon lawn
3-pointer that's good Eric Gordon from
downtown and it's back to to ratchet the
game plan on a finishing results of
going to Durant and curry says Nene no
no knocks down the shot five-point game
harden to the basket lays it up and
banks it home with a foul thanks Hobson
picks up his fourth foul curry crossover
three-pointer
screams defense ever-present get off the
klay Thompson reports on the loose ball
hit lured in by rivers usually they put
eyedrops in there as well capela once
again uncovered as it comes off the weak
side and slams it home green and
couldn't knock it away the other way it
out of 10
he just picked up for Golden State
Tucker in the corner in Philly for
clothes
thirty-five-year-old missing right there
it's hardened the other way by green for
there is capela
there's the alley from hard
[Applause]
watch the ball rivers his dad
[Applause]
it's Jeff Kurr the other way another six
to play in between
rocket ships posting to deploy please
download to really assist both Paul and
Hardin have to drive they're not coming
to help
[Applause]
a sensational defensive play stopping
what would have been a dunk by Iguodala
as Lisa Salters reported at the top of
the telecast the doctor couldn't believe
he played with it Duran the Euro step
Tucker tried to stay will endure ahead
just too good and it's back to one
Durant has 41 I mean what he does on the
floor he leaves it as a coach as a
former player is inspired
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Martin tonight three of seven Thompson's
defense there step back he's done it
again
Edgar Dawa defended by Shumpert
three buzzer-beating
triple by Iguodala when I shot by curry
two-point game